all right let's see what is continuing
to be on people's minds on the phones at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 lots of folks holding
on let's go let's go to Deon we haven't
heard from Deon in the 4 1 7 for several
months actually close to a year Deon
what's going on hi how's it going yeah I
haven't called in a quite a while
good I I had a like I don't know if it's
a question as much as a statement that I
think we mischaracterized things with
left and right dichotomy too much when
it's more of a it's like informed
misinformed and dissing forms yes that
is the cause sometimes that's the case
but I think there's other wisdom so
sometimes we miss characterized
positions as left right when really it's
the fact-based position and the one
that's not
sometimes we mischaracterizing because
the analysis is really one about you
know for example corruption versus
anti-corruption but listen Dion it
sounds crazy where you are so I don't
know if you had a specific part I could
answer offline but I can barely hear you
oh I'm sorry I'm on a wired headphones
is this a better connection you know
it's not a connection it just sounds
like chaos in the background I don't
know if you're at a daycare or something
like that oh no I'm not I'll let you go
okay
alrighty I'm great to hear from you I
appreciate it you are completely right
sometimes it's not about left versus
right
sometimes it's about do you know the
facts or don't you and I love it I
appreciate that
Dion called in and and made that very
important point